I I could wear full clown makeup I'm
still gonna get recognized you know what
that's actually two things that you just
brought up that I wanted to talk to you
about one
you get recognized by your voice a lot
right so then the same thing so our
Dynamic didn't do [ __ ] right because you
and I were in the people like that Stevo
and then you drive it's like boom for
sure and then the other thing I was
going to talk to you about is that you
used to be a clown that you started out
as a clown and I went to Circus School
in like Paris France and I also I'm a
juggler I know we understand we're told
that you juggle during your stand-up
yeah I have a special coming out next
year called philosophy circus
and there's yeah there's like juggling
there's terrible ventriloquism somebody
in the audience plays the trombone like
it's like very circus and this is
already shot yeah sorry wow I shot two
hour-long specials in three weeks two
completely separate specials because I
was like we got to get these done and
then move on to the San Diego special
and get that ready I gotta stop
preparing with to shoot specials that
I'm ready to shoot
um but I love circus that's why I love
jackass so much because it has a lot of
elements of circus and when I read that
about you I was like oh that makes
perfect sense yeah because circus is
like don't think just love just laugh
just be amazed just yeah and that's what
I love about circus and I really always
thought of Jackass like similar to a
circus and nobody ever brings that up
because they just don't think of that
connection but that's great because you
are a clown I'm a clown also but we're
sort of not traditional clowns right
which you would think of when you think
of clown for sure so uh what what kind
of juggling do you do juggle balls so I
can do that I can juggle up to five
balls but in wow the leap from four to
five is a substantial leap are they
called the black belt of juggling as if
you can do five then you're like a
master joke you do it like when you're
juggling four balls all that means is
you're just doing two any chance
everybody watching is like oh my God but
yeah jump to five is really different
you can do five I've never gotten
anywhere near five I had to just do it I
was actually at a circus camp as a
counselor teaching stilt walking and
juggling and every day I would just go
and practice for like five hours six
hours how long can you sustain five
balls for a while I can get through the
pattern for like yeah for like a couple
minutes but not I couldn't do it in
perpetuity I'm gonna drop one eventually
right so what you do when you juggle
five is you hit it right until it's
impressive and then you catch them and
you're like I'm done I could have done
it forever
uh but what I juggle is I juggle them
you know flaming I can juggle torches
knives can you pass clubs I can pass
clubs yeah but my favorite thing and
what's in a special is cigar boxes okay
so those are the three blocks that you
move around sure that's really cool I'm
very good at those I'm actually a member
of The Magic Castle in Los Angeles wow
nice because of that because WC Fields
popularize that and then I can also do
these things called Shaker cups which is
like apps that stack and you do all that
so those are the actually the two types
of um that's exactly how you do it yeah
yeah same way you jack off a bunch of
guys
uh and so um those are the ones that I
find really interesting but in the
philosophy circus I juggle glow in the
dark balls I tell a scary story to
everybody and then uh I do been it's so
bizarre but I do have ventriloquist
dummy bit at the end of dear Jonah and
then just because I I had to change it
to that for the pandemic then
um I did a there's a ventriloquist dummy
bit at the end of philosophy circus so
it's really funny to me that when people
say when people see this next special
after the dear Jonah they're gonna be
like is he gonna start closing every
special with a ventriloquist dummy thing
is that like who he is but it's not it's
just those two work so well in these
specials so all right yeah yeah yeah but
that's crazy so did you do were you did
you not get into clown college for
Ringling brothers or you did I did you
really did yeah that's what I wanted to
do after high school it was tough to get
in it was a big deal and they ended the
program correct I graduated in 2000. I
graduated in the last class ever which
was the class of 1997. so I I was
graduating in 99 and I would have
applied in 98 but it was over that's
amazing yeah I'm so jealous of you for
that thing alone yeah it's got all the
ball stuff you went to Paris to go to
Circus school yeah so that's what I
ended up having to do but that was in
college and I got a um
I got a scholarship to that so I just
had to get myself there so you're like
[ __ ] I can't get in the Ringling
Brothers Circus so then you went to
Paris yeah so but I would have rather
done an American clown college this was
great but mostly in Paris I learned
still walking and it was more like body
movement French Cirque du Soleil type
[ __ ] I wanted to just do like hit
yourself on the head with a giant
inflatable Sledgehammer fall down and
get in the car like that that American
clowning I think is really interesting
because it's more jackassy yeah it's
more Three Stooges a little bit you know
why'd you get it why I know you've
talked about it before but like you
wanted to go in it for the art of the
circus why did you want to go into the
circus I had my heart set on becoming a
crazy famous stunt man you know it
started it started out as a
skateboarding led me to the video camera
I was like
I'm not going to be a professional
skateboarder I'm not that good but I
love making videos I'm just want to be
crazy with my if I just found really
crazy crap with my home video camera I
want that to be my career yeah yeah
which is crazy because there was no
precedent for that and and that somehow
we made I made it work but um the uh
the idea was like I'm gonna be a stunt
man and and I wasn't getting any
traction and then while living with my
sister and my sister found out about
clown college like like uh it occurred
to me I was like okay well maybe people
will take me more seriously as a
stuntman if I'm a trained circus
professional it was like a sort of a
means to an end I was trying to I only
went to clown college to further my goal
of becoming a famous crazy professional
stunt man so that was sort of your back
door way into being a motorcyclist in
the globe or those if that was gonna be
it perhaps I just wanted to be taken
more seriously for lighting myself on
fire at backyard keg parties
I love that and the way to do that the
validation of your experiences was the
clown right yeah I'm the only guy who
went to clown college seeking legitimacy
that's exactly right for sure oh my God
that's so funny yeah I mean you had to
like act to the public like I mean
they are expression where did you study
they broke it down they broke clown
cards down into like you know hour-long
classes that went throughout the day so
you had like an hour of dance class you
had an hour uh like whatever like all
kinds of dance you had uh an hour of uh
of acrobatics you know an hour of skills
you know and an hour of a circus history
you know you'd put on your makeup for
for it I'd be an hour of makeup like um
every day you would do this yeah so it's
like class but like the wow those are
the places yeah there's legit classes
would break for lunch for an hour we'd
go back to more classes so can you
really dance no
now you you never you didn't the only
thing that you had to do uh was to walk
on stilts you had to be proficient still
Walker beyond that it was just sort of
an exercise in trying to to uh just
highlight your strengths yeah find your
clown right you're trying to figure out
what your clown was going to be right is
there like a defined different types of
clown like a type of clown yeah for sure
but what kind of clown are you or what
kind of clown are you well there's three
distinct types of clown there's
um like for lack of a better word the
the hobo clown which is like Emmett
Kelly that's right yeah you know that
that's sort of its own kind of clown and
then there's ramp they call that
sometimes yeah and then and then the
other two is the white face clown and
the Auguste Clown and and they base this
on um cartoon characters like Tom and
Jerry there's uh like one is like you
know Tom is the cat he's like dumb like
some runs into the wall and Jerry's like
the straight face like more kind of like
clever you know like in all the cartoons
there's the the the the straight one and
there's the dumb one that like crashes
into the wall all the time so I was the
dumb one that crashes into the wall all
the time that's perfect it's called the
August clown and then the white face
clown is gonna be like your Jerry so
when you see like a bunch of clowns
acting out all of them are acting out
one of three different characters uh in
a traditional sub version yeah they
would sort of say is you'd say okay what
ever but finding your clown your yours
would be like there's also the archetype
the butthole burner but and that's just
someone who has their butthole burning
the whole time
that type of thing yeah um no but you
find kind of what are your strengths
like you were saying and then you kind
of plug that into what your clown would
be I I I would say and in different
different countries is different Russian
clowns are different than French clowns
or different American clowns but it does
all kind of come to those three yeah I
would submit too that there's also like
just straight skills clowns you know
like you could be a clown and just your
deal is just that you're gonna juggle
the whole time you think you can start a
clown college school and teach all the
classes I wouldn't want to do that and
yeah but you could you could right I
suppose I I you can write a curriculum
I I could but uh I out of respect for
the art I don't think that I think would
be interesting is for you to kind of
teach stunt clowning
perhaps you know but I I think when I
was just blown away by is that knowing
that I can see so much of that in your
work and it's a way to kind of go back
and look at his [ __ ] from the past and
see the way he reacts to the camera and
when he actually gets hurt how he sort
of expresses that it's really I mean
it's really really interesting because I
just I didn't know that about you until
just recently once I found out that I
was maybe come on the podcast and so I I
we I read that and it just clicked I was
like of course he's a clown that makes
perfect sense and that's you know coming
from a clown so yeah I mean I've worked
as a clown like that that uh my clown
career afforded me the ability to not
sell drugs for a living yeah I went from
from selling a terribly short
underweight bags of weed to earning a
legitimate living as a clown right up
until the day that uh I was shooting the
jackass series actually as a matter of
fact I uh washed off my clown makeup in
the circus for the very last time within
a half an hour of barfing up the
goldfish in the iconic goldfish yeah oh
my God Knoxville in the MTV crew
actually came to film me perform in the
circus for what turned out to be my last
ever performance in the circus and uh we
went straight from there to do they have
that footage yeah yeah I think they even
showed that footage in that uh demise
and Rise documentary about my downward
spiral into addiction that would be cool
footage to grab your last footage as a
clown yeah they I did a simultaneous
fire breathing backflip off the top rung
of a stepladder really I don't think I
landed it particularly cleanly but
yeah that's so great yeah I think in
everything that I do if you know that
I'm a clown then you see the movies I've
been in especially Ehrlich from Silicon
Valley is a very clown he's very false
staff in oh my gosh you know and so you
see him when he knocks stuff over the
way that I interact with stuff we're
talking about the faga yogurt it's just
uh all of that kind of comes back down
to clown and in that I gained weight for
that movie and I created a clown wig
with my hair and so it if you look at
that character now knowing that it's
supposed to be a clown you're like oh
that makes perfect sense I think that
clip was awesome but not as awesome as
my new book a hard kick in the nuts what
I've learned from a lifetime of terrible
decisions my first books Five star rated
on Amazon and I have no doubt this one
will be too should get the autograph
copy right now at stevo.com
yeah dude